il s'agit principalement d'aménager des
chambres pour les parents donc à
proximité de leurs enfants hospitalisés
reportage marié delbono bernard colas
pour la deuxième année consécutive
maeve récupère les pièces jaunes elle a
vingt jours pour en collecter un maximum
deux millions et demi de tirelires comme
celles ci ont été mises à la disposition
des enfants dont dix sept mille bureaux
de poste de la cousine est resté
longtemps à l'hôpital quand il était
tout jeannie
j'ai été touché par par cette action
l'argent collecté sert à améliorer la
vie des enfants à l'hôpital
l'an dernier 23 millions de francs on
servait à financer 279 projets dans les
hôpitaux comme cette chambre qui permet
à la mère de rester avec son enfant
pendant toute la durée de
l'hospitalisation
si génial et j'espère qu'il y en a ras
plus parce qu'il ya que l a pas beaucoup
dans le service malheureusement c'est un
peu dommage
et vous vous imaginez rentrez chez vous
tous les soirs elle a laissé ici
non impossible c'est vraiment un faux si
25000 francs en plus jeunes ont été
consacrés à la réalisation de cette
salle a lieu tout en couleurs consacré
au jeu trente mille francs pour cette
petite maison où stéphanie aime à se
réfugier pour lire l'opération pièces
jaunes
elle sait ce que c'est un magnétoscope
de 4,7 pour s'occuper
autre exemple ce studio vidéo depuis 90
800 projets ont été ainsi financé jamais
de matériel médical mais tout ce qui
peut adoucir la vie de l'enfant à
l'hôpital puisqu'il lui rappelle sa
maison ou son école